Welcome back to the David Pakman show. Earlier
this week I interviewed David Wallace wells
about the climate and the sort of
urgent nature of what is taking place currently
and the seemingly intractable situation that
we're up against with when it comes to protecting
the environment and protecting humanity from
humanity effectively and the effect that we
are having on the climate and on the planet
via industrialization and pollution and burning
of fossil fuels. For today's classic interview,
we're going to go back to my interview with
David Keith from a couple of years ago where
we spoke about Geo engineering. We didn't
speak about geoengineering in the conspiratorial
sense. We spoke about it in the sense of as
a climate change mitigating mechanism. Uh,
let's check out that interview right now.
I'm joined today by David Keith, who is professor
of engineering and of public policy at Harvard
University. Uh, you've worked in the field
of climate science, energy technology. You've
been in public policy. It's so interesting
now what we are seeing with regard to it.
I think that geoengineering is sort of crossing
a lot of these areas that you've worked in
and it's touching on a lot of different aspects
that are increasingly present sort of in the
narrative. Let's start for people who don't
know what we're talking about. What's Geo
Engineering?
So the idea of solar geoengineering is the
idea that humanity might, um, deliberately
make the earth a little bit more reflective
by some technological means like putting some
kind of aerosol, a fine dust into the stratosphere
perhaps, and that that would partially and
in perfectly and in permanently offset some
of the risks, the climate risks that comes
from the accumulation of carbon dioxide in
the atmosphere.
And is this just in terms of preventing temperature
increases or are there other potential benefits?
Certainly not just temperature. Climate changes,
a whole host of things from changes in extreme
temperature, changes in rainfall patterns,
changes in sea level, uh, changes in the,
um, impacts on the natural environment on,
on, um, species and ecosystems and the evidence,
uh, which it certainly comes from lots of
uncertainty. But the evidence is that a moderate
amount of solar geoengineering, something
that say, cut the overall rate of climate
change or it's warming if you like in half,
would uh, reduce changes both in temperature
but also reduce, uh, changes, increases in
precipitation. Yeah. Perhaps increase, reducing
the, uh, the increase in extreme storms that
are the things particularly destructive to
the poorest people in the world.
Specifically, how would this be done? In other
words, what would be the sort of technological
mechanisms that would be used to carry out
such a policy?
So in some ways that's the easiest part. The
hard questions are mostly all about governance
and science. Well, we'll get to that. I think
it's, yeah, exactly. But I think it's reasonably
clear that at least in this one method, putting
aerosols in the stratosphere, that really
existing technology, essentially existing
aircraft technologies could be used to put
say, you know, some amount that we'll wrap
up from zero gradually to maybe over a sort
of 25 or 50 years, just something like a million
tons a year of material going into the stratosphere.
And that that could be done really with off
the shelf aircraft technology that many nations
could access and could be supplied by many
vendors. That kind of variance of the technology
that you see in a a business jet. Um, nothing
all that fancy. So the basic ability get Michelle
says tries fear is something that uh, can
be done at cost and aren't very different
from the costs of shipping materials by air
freight across the Pacific.
One of the criticisms that I've read of this
type of geoengineering is that although it
might be effective in terms of the mitigation
of climate change, that there are all sorts
of other negative potential environmental
repercussions depending on what specifically
is used as an aerosol, have the development
accelerated in terms of solving that issue
over the last several years versus maybe in
the early nineties when there were earlier
discussions of this technology.
I think the big perspective here is that because
of concerns, some I think very well found
the legitimate and some may be a little bitch.
I'm kind of at the gut level because of concerns
about this technology. There isn't a large
organized research program. So for example
though the United States is often seen as
a place of sort of technological optimism,
uh, uh, justifiably so. And it though there's
a huge overall budget for climate research
with several billion a year, not counting
all the money that we spend. And we should
spend much more, in my opinion, on cutting
emissions. There has been no organized us
government research and any kind on solar
sharing and, and very little globally. There's
small research programs now and in Europe
and China and so I'm in the U S I helped to
run one, but they're funded dominantly by
philanthropic money. These stars is uh, because
there's been very, very little government
money. So that that the important answer at
this point is that we don't know very much.
There's, there's, there's plenty and I can
tell you some of what we do know, but to be
clear, the argument that I, and I think many
people like me are making is not that we ought
to do geo missionary. I think that would be
ridiculous. The argument is that we ought
to have a serious coordinated open access
or church program to understand more about
how well it would work, what the risks are,
how would control it
on the Internet. If you were to, for example,
prepare with an intern for an interview with
someone like you and Research Geo engineering,
you would inevitably come across all sorts
of conspiracy theories about Geo engineering.
Sometimes the term climate engineering is
used, you will then probably go down the Internet
rabbit hole into chem trails. And I've interviewed
one or two of the, the chem trails conspiracy
theorists. How did this start that Geo engineering
became so tied into some of the, I guess I
would call them not at, not making a value
judgment, but merely from the way that, that
the material is presented, some of the juiciest
conspiracy theories on the Internet. Well,
how did this develop?
I don't know is the short answer. I think
from what I understand, there were um, long
held beliefs by probably a very tiny number
of people that the u s government was sort
of deliberately manipulating the ionosphere
through something called the harp program,
which was a, uh, actually a pretty normal
nerdy physics program to try and beam microwave
Cynthiana sphere. Um, and, and a bunch of
related programs that people who kind of want
to see some nefarious, um, coordinated action
imagined were happening. And then as the more
public discussion of solar, you make sure.
And he began to be more visible, say a decade.
Um, those two ideas where somehow conflated,
I don't know why, what I think is clear is
that, um, the extraordinary spread as social
media has really changed the way these things
work so that, um, there's much more, you know,
it's much easier to produce fake news as we've
seen in lots of countries including the u
s and the last few years.
It's much easier to produce materials that
are pure too naive viewers to be convincing.
And so you can get many more people falling
into the trap of believing stuff that, you
know, uh, objective lead to the mainstream
seems really bizarre. Uh, and, and extraordinarily
unlikely to be true. And that's true on all
sorts of cases, but this is certainly a particularly
odd one and it stirs up a pretty high level
of, of, of hatred and anger on the Internet.
And I think it probably will affect the kind
of normal discussion of do you mind sharing,
which itself is controversial but in totally
different ways.
Let's talk now a little bit about the sort
of politics and governance issues around this.
I mean certainly I think we can all imagine
how if you go up into the sky and you start
spraying aerosols or whatever it is ultimately
used, those aerosols are not going to respect
to these imaginary lines on maps called country
borders. So logistically who needs to agree
to such a program? What are the sort of governance
obstacles that that would be presented?
That's a very hard question and it's a, it's
a, it's an emerging question. I mean for all
of these, um, global public goods, um, and
I think that's ultimately what this is. If
it makes any sense, including goods that of
course, like any of them have some risks and
side effects the way we manage them. Is it
an emerging isn't, it was a work in progress.
So that's true for managing pollution. The
ozone layer, it's true for magic global climate.
It's true for, for managing infectious diseases
and, and all sorts of things. So there isn't
a simple for me that for what's legitimate.
Um, obviously international organizations
matter, but soda coalitions of individual
countries and I think it will be some mixture
of, of what some individual countries do,
what environmental groups or other um, uh,
transnational, um, public organizations do.
Uh, and, and what the international relations
like the United Nations do. So it's really
hard to guess. What I think is really hopeful
is that are are now serious emerging efforts
to look at what that, how that governance
would work. So for example, the guy called
on was pasture, who is the lead advisor to
the secretary general for climate is now running
in an effort to try and develop a governance
for solar geoengineering.
One of the concerns that I have that I know
is shared by at least some people in my audience
with regard to whatever we may ultimately
decide to do to try to deal with a human caused
climate change, is that rather than taking
a development like Geo engineering or a new
form of energy, whatever the case may be,
and saying, okay, now we can use this to actually
make a net improvement to what we're doing
to the climate, that it will be seen at least
by some as sort of carte blanche to keep doing
exactly what we're doing. Right? Saying, hey,
now instead of just improving the situation,
we'll keep doing what we're doing, but we
won't be doing as much damage because we've
come up with this new thing. How do we deal
with that?
Well, I mean, I think that is the, the central
fear that beyond any other has held back research
this topic. And, and I think there's ways
in which it's both deeply legitimate and,
and some ways that it's less so. So, yeah,
of course there will be some interests, uh,
interest for example, in parts of the fossil
fuel industry, they would like to keep the
party going and not reduce fossil fuel consumption.
Uh, the hard truth is that if you want a stable
climate, you have to bring fossil to consumption
to zero eventually. And nothing about silver
Jewish or any changes that you must bring
emissions to zero in the net solar Jewish
and can reduce the risks of climate change
for CEO to, it's already in the air but it
can't eliminate them. And so I think it's
certainly true that some forces allied with,
uh, saved the fossil fuel industry that doesn't
want to see climate regulation might use the
possibility of solar Jewish entering as an
excuse for inaction.
But, um, the question is how powerful those
versus really be in the end. The political
forces that want to see our climate protected
need to win anyway. And I think gradually
we, we are beginning to, when we are being
in to win the battle to restrict co two emissions.
And I don't think that adding something that
further reduces perhaps significantly reduces
the risks to the most vulnerable in the planet,
which is what sold or Jewish or and could
do. I don't think that in the long game that
suddenly means that we lose the political
ability to cut emissions, but I agree it's
a legitimate at hard question. Okay.
All right. Something we will be dealing with
certainly for years to come. We've been speaking
with David Keith, professor of Engineering
and public policy at Harvard University.
Thanks so much for talking to us about this.
Thanks a lot. It's great to be on your show.